you can be intentional about your
character
you can have money and a career you are
the hero
in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb
cash is king and the paid off home
mortgage has taken the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice i'm dave
ramsey your host thank you for joining
us america
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five that's triple eight eight
two five
five two two five david is going to
start off
this hour calling us from jerusalem no
less
israel hey david how are you i'm fine
dave thank god how are you i know
i know the answer but how are you better
than i deserve sir how can i help
awesome uh well first of all thank you
so much for taking the call
um we love what you do thank you our
ten-year-old daughter
has around forty six thousand dollars in
a family trust
the trust allows distributions to pay
for college but it triggers a capital
gains tax whenever that distribution is
taken
her my dad her grandfather has suggested
we take a distribution of about 21 000
now really plus the tax burden so let's
call it say
26 or 27. net of tax would be 21 000 to
buy
a prepaid college fund from from the
state of florida where we're moving back
to
no and okay no and even though that
guarantees four years no matter how high
the costs and tuition go in the future
and no matter what happens in the stock
market yeah the um
what you're guaranteeing is the rate of
return on your money is the inflation
rate of tuition
tuition inflation rate for the last 58
years is 7.2 percent
average okay i guess everyone's a little
worried about what it's been for like
for the last eight to ten
everyone's a lot of things but the
actual math
is that it doesn't go up at all doesn't
go up at all doesn't go up at all and
then they spike it one year
and so everybody goes into drama queen
mode uh where you're much better off
i think to invest in good growth stock
mutual funds if you have that option
and um in a 529 where it's growing
tax-free
and you're gonna outpace you're gonna
outpace the growth rate
of inflation for tuition okay so that's
the second part of the question
would you take a distribution now and
put that
net into a 529 now to grow tax-free yes
or just leave it yeah and not leave
where it is to grow tax deferred
right because tax deferred obviously is
all going to be taxed later tax free is
going to be tax
free later and um
i'm also making a quick assumption here
that the funds in that trust fund
probably aren't invested in good growth
stock mutual funds
uh no i think they are okay we've talked
about it okay good
well so you either okay so here's what
we're gonna do then
let's assume the exact same rates of
return
in your equation right yeah so you leave
it alone
and it grows at
we'll call it eleven percent okay it
grows at ten eleven percent okay
and uh and one hundred percent of what
you take out is taxed
or you take it out now and you pay a
fifteen percent
capital gains i'm sorry i should i'm
sorry interrupt i should tell you most
of the principle was
family gifts so it'd only be taxed on
the capital gains above the gift amount
okay so a 15 so we're not reducing the
account
at as whole by 15 we're reducing it by
maybe
five percent or whatever right right
then
then it's going to grow from there 100
tax-free so would we rather have
we'll make up a number 95 of this
account that grows from now until
college 100
tax-free at 10 or 11 or would we
rather it grow tax deferred and all of
it be taxed
or virtually all of it be taxed all the
growth be taxed
uh when you get there so the difference
is tax on all of that growth
versus a five percent cut today and um
that's there's you're gonna you're gonna
come out with the tax free much better
off
got it okay thanks so much you see how i
did that
i i do and and the longer the longer it
stays
in the family trust the more the greater
percentage of it will end up being
capital gains because it's going to keep
compounding
exactly and the greater percentage of it
will be
yeah it'll be taxable and uh if we were
putting it into an account
that became uh taxed at ordinary income
later versus
leaving it there in capital gains we
wouldn't do that we'd leave it in
capital gains because that's a lower tax
rate
right but that's not the case in the
case of the 529 you're putting
uh how much is in the account well for
her about 46 000 right now
okay all right yeah you're gonna have to
look at we'll see with a smart vester
pro or somebody to help you select a 529
that will allow that much you may have
to move it in two tranches
uh some one year some this year some
next year in order to get it all moved
but either way the
the principle still stands that uh the
concept still stands that you're going
to be better off to with a tax-free
growth than a capital gains growth
assuming exact same rates of return so
interesting call man thank you
appreciate you checking in hope things
are going well there in israel
i'm ready for you guys to open back up
over there so we can come visit again
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five jonathan
is with us in olympia washington hi
jonathan how are you
i'm doing good dave about yourself
better than i deserve what's up
uh hey i just uh had a question for you
we are
my wife and i are on baby step two and
things have been going pretty good
um over the last year we paid off about
thirty thousand dollars in debt
way to go um thank you yeah the only
problem i'm having i have the
the ramsey plus every dollar app going
on and everything
but the problem we have is
the miscellaneous category things that
we don't buy every month
um i'm trying to keep it within the
parameters that i've set
is it seems like it's almost impossible
i know it's not but it's just it's hard
to
plan for what might come up like for
instance you know we just got a
little twenty thirty dollar things you
know death by a thousand because
hey um like we just got a puppy and we
they would get a baby gate for it
you know and uh to keep it from going
all over the house was
twenty thirty dollars or we ship off uh
a package to a family member and pay the
postage for that you know another
fifteen
twenty dollars how what's the best way
to
really keep that in check and where
we're not
you know arguing over it all the time
for these things that we don't really
know
what's going to come up
how much are you putting in there um i
have a set of 100
a month okay and and so the discussion
is how long you been doing this
how many months um since
last may so almost a year okay so out of
a year
how many times has this been a problem
every month
pretty much yeah okay
is it the sense that one of you thinks
the other one is overspending
or have you just simply underfunded this
account
that's kind of what i'm wondering if
maybe i've underfunded i mean i try to
be really
strict and i have you know i have
adjusted the budget every month like you
say
it can change um do you have good
records
you have good records on uh if we want
to get real nerdy on where the money
went that came out of that account
um probably not that great
i mean it's from here now so there's
there's two options okay there's two
options one is lighten it up a little
bit just make it 150 and let's move on
okay
uh okay and there's nothing wrong with
that because you're just recognizing
that you have a miscellaneous need that
is higher than you've been budgeting for
and we need to have reality in the
budget versus mythology
the second thing you could do is you
could find a trend that
a certain you need a new category that
splices off
and you need to put 50 in that new
category that keeps showing up in this
miscellaneous over and over
and i don't know what that new category
is it could be puppy i don't know what
it is but
and you know that could be that that
category is what's draining you dry
life is full of firsts
as the first and longest serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since
1981. we believe you should have the
freedom to focus on your health while
being supported by a community of
believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more firsts
thank you for joining us america our
famous ten dollar sale
is back it's here you can now learn how
to make
faster and real progress with your money
when you check out our famous ten dollar
sale
you save up to sixty percent on over 40
of our best
selling books and budgeting tools like
debt-free degree
from anthony o'neil the proximity
principal from ken coleman
plus these of course make great gifts
you can shop the 10 sale at the online
store
at ramseysolutions.com you can get all
of my books there at ten dollars all of
rachel's i think the new one even is
down to ten now
so check it all out and uh man there's
some deals there
that's uh that's uh and while you're
there you can register to win our
uh ramsey cash giveaway we're giving
away five hundred dollars every week
and a grand prize of five thousand
dollars cash of course no purchase
necessary
got to be 18 to win you can enter daily
so text cash to 33 789 if you want to
register for that
cash 233 789 and of course ramsey
solutions.com on the store
that's where the ten dollar special is
shane is in mobile alabama hi shane
how are you uh better than i deserve
that you publish yourself
just the same sir how can i help um
well my mother is set to receive a
settlement
from an accident probably in the sum of
maybe the hundred thousand dollar range
and of course because i've been through
your financial peace university and
stuff like that
i'm the son that she calls for financial
advice good
um you know when i told her i said you
know i said let's
i said let's call dave and see what dave
has to say because
my mother is 60 my father's 65 he's set
to retire this year
and i told her i said i just don't want
y'all to blow this money
let's call see what they say maybe they
have an elp
local you know somewhere around
huntsville they can talk with y'all and
you know try to steer you in the right
direction
okay all right so what's the rest of
their financial situation look like
um i don't want a lot to you
so i know they have a house i'm not sure
i want to say maybe it has
five or six years left on it that they
could possibly pay off vehicles are paid
for
um and things of that nature so they've
been pretty responsible
yes sir yeah these people aren't acting
like they're in congress or something
no sir no sir she she just you know
she's um
i will say this she they kind of help my
little brother out who lives up there
near him and that's what i told her i
said just
you know i said do what you do i kind of
don't want to don't don't call them ask
me for something and then get mad when i
tell you
you know what you need to hear not what
you want to hear oh good for you
good for you that's a good word um
well i i think the the biggest thing is
people like that that are fairly
responsible don't do stupid things on
purpose
they do them on accident because they
did not have a purpose
and so the wisest thing i can tell you
is they do need to decide before the
money gets here
exactly where it's going to go we're
going to put 10 000 on this we're going
to put 8 000 on that
we're going to give the little brother 2
000. uh we're going to invest it we're
going to pay off the house
i don't know you know whatever but every
one of those dollars
and it doesn't all have to be one place
is my point but every one of those
dollars
needs an assignment before the money
gets here because if it doesn't get an
assignment that's when the money has a
tendency to wander off
exactly and even with somebody that's
responsible because they feel like they
hit the lottery now is she okay from the
accident is everybody okay
medically yes sir yes sir she uh she
actually
got um she had she had back surgery
probably five years ago which had
nothing to do with the accident
she you know she retired and like i said
my dad he just had shoulder surgery two
weeks ago
so you think they've got a little bit of
a mortgage and that's it
yes sir if i'm not mistaken that's it
but you know no no loans or anything
like that because
well i would make sure they had an
emergency fund i'd make sure they had an
emergency fund i would you know pay off
the house
um i would give some of it
i would enjoy some of it and i would
invest some of it
okay that's that's kind of kind of where
i was at and kind of along my lines but
i just needed your professional opinion
on that yeah the idea that you
don't give any of it is a bad idea i
don't care how much
the idea that you don't enjoy any of it
and you're like
hyper responsible we're gonna invest
every penny and we're gonna have no fun
at all
no i think you need to have some of the
money and it doesn't have to be a lot
it's just a matter of what feels good
a little bit we're just going to have
some fun with this money we're going to
give
some of this money we're going to invest
some of this money we'll pay off the
house and make sure we have an emergency
fund in place that
those kinds of categories is where i
would dump this money and all of that of
course is following right down the baby
steps
and um you know but if you can get them
to commit
on a simple yellow pad exactly where the
hundred is going before it gets there
that's a touchdown you just scored
because they're gonna they'll follow
through on what they write down on that
one little yellow pad
one page they'll do it and they'll feel
weird if they don't
once they think it through but if you
just chunk it in the checking account
you'll look up and go well little
brother got half of it you know or
something stupid but thing like that and
that's not gonna be okay
uh navin is navin i guess is with us in
cleveland ohio is it naven yeah it's
nevin
nevin i got it wrong sorry about that
okay nevin how can i help
good question for you so i work for a
family-owned or family-run construction
company here in ohio
and currently i'm driving my personal
pickup truck for both
personal use company use whatever and
long story short my dad would want me to
upgrade to quite a bit of a newer truck
and uh the company would be paying for
they would give an allowance of 25 000
for this truck and anything on top of
that i would have to pay
out of pocket and then that truck would
be
i guess i could use it for company use
and personal use
and i guess i'm just not sure yeah what
to think about
this type of deal and pretty much the
truck would be in the company's name
then
just looking to get some advice on it
okay um if the company's gonna if the
truck's gonna be in the company's name
the company needs to pay for the truck
okay so you don't put listen pretend
like pretend like this wasn't your
parents okay
let's say you were working for me and i
said okay i want you to put in ten
thousand
i'm gonna put in 25 000 and i'm gonna
own the truck
i would never do it yeah well it's dumb
so no
company needs to own the truck and the
company needs to pay for the truck so
if papa wants you to have a truck then
he needs to pony up
the cash
what if what if uh i guess i'm a legal
partner in the company what does that
change anything if
in the next say five years we'd be
looking to
take over quite a bit of the company if
you if you own 51
or more then you're making all the
decisions and you are the company
okay but right now you're not
okay until you are that no i mean i own
my company so what
what i title my cars to whether i title
them to my personal name
or one of my companies or one of my
other companies is irrelevant since i
own all three
right it's irrelevant it's just a
titling issue at that point
but this is this is more of a what is
best for
uh you you know that's that's what we're
asking here and
no you don't buy a 35 000 truck and put
it in the company name and you put up 10
grand in it no
so if they want what's your truck worth
that you're driving
that's about 5 000 right now okay we'll
move up to a 25 000 our trucks pretty
substantial so that's enough of a truck
yeah for sure one and that that's the
other question where
they're writing a check for 25 000 cash
right
yeah okay they're not signing you up for
payments on 25
000. either way if the company buys it i
buy
either either way at the cash deal it's
a debt free company as well we do
everything with cash
okay good good and here's the thing okay
uh just i grew up in the real estate
business the construction business i've
been around it my whole life
and uh the idea that you're taking a
nice new pickup
onto a construction site is pretty
absurd if you've been on construction
sites very long you know the guys with
the junkiest pickups are the ones that
have the most money
and the ones that look like a dadgum
silverado commercial or broke people
with payments
yep and so don't this would be a it's a
cash transaction
i got that but i don't know what we're
trying to prove here five thousand
dollar pickup will do everything on a
construction site that a 25 000 pickup
will do who are we trying to impress
the subs give me a break
but if he wants to write a check and you
guys think you want to do it there's
nothing wrong with it
as long as he's paying for it and it
goes into the company name and he puts
up the 25k
nothing wrong with that but don't put no
we don't need 26k and we certainly don't
need 35k
with your money being on top
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers
to recommend blinds.com is no exception
they offer high quality window
treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades
and interior shutters with easy online
ordering
free shipping and a guaranteed perfect
fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's
special savings
so
thank you for joining us america we're
here to talk to you about your
life and your money open phones are
triple eight eight two five
five two two five brian is
with us in kansas city hey brian welcome
to the ramsay show
hi dave thank you um so my question
today
is uh basically me and my wife decided
that this was going to be the best year
to build a house and we're kind of
finding out
that's not really true so
we went under contract two months ago
gave our current tractor the earnest
money and the deposit haven't really
heard a lot back from our contractor
um they haven't broken ground yet
and then last week we got an email that
said
due to material prices increasing they
have to raise the price of us
um of the materials and they have to
raise the price of the house
so um basically i kind of pushed back on
that went back and forth with them for a
little bit
and they said in the contract that
there's
paragraph 30 they have the right to
raise the price based on material
um so to look to my mortgage guy
and he had his legal team look at it
and it looks like the only out that we
have
is if the loan gets denied they
illegally have to give us our money back
um what do you think about the morality
of that
does that seem like a moral choice
that's good does it not um
just your thoughts that you that you
walk away from the deal
yes sir okay uh not the morality of them
raising prices
so what is the how much did they raise
the prices
uh 3.5 percent so it was about ten
thousand dollars
uh and the other thing in the email they
said is that they can no longer
lock down prices with their vendors so
whenever they order say lumber for frame
of the house whatever the price of
lumber is that day
is what we'll have to pay so it looks
like the price of the house is going to
increase also
more than what they've already told you
yes sir
okay and what's the price range of the
home what is the price overall
uh the price was 314
and it's about 325 now okay
and what's your household income
about 90 000 okay
well
um to start with let's just say that
what they're telling you is the truth
lumber is going up rapidly that's not a
lie
um and i and they have the
contractual ability to raise the price
and my guess is the market's hot enough
that if you don't buy the house they can
sell
somebody else
i would agree yeah so i i don't think
they're going to be harmed
in this situation um
but basically you'd have to get a turn
down letter turning you down for the
loan from your mortgage broker
yeah he said that's no problem okay
all right um
i don't have an issue with the morality
i mean the deal has
changed uh nobody in this deal
anticipated that the deal was going to
change
uh and based on the change you don't
want to be in the deal
you know i don't want to be in a house
that i feel like
i kind of got you know the
bad end of the stick i don't i don't
think you're getting the batting of the
stick i think i think if you're
if you were building a cost plus house
which is how i build mine
meaning i buy i pay the costs and i pay
the builders a flat fee to manage the
project
you would be absorbing all of the
increases
i'm building a commercial building that
we break ground on a conference center
here
and our steel prices doubled and we
hadn't even broke ground yet
and i'm that's all on me because the
contractor just
manages the project in a commercial
project they don't
they don't it's not it's not a turnkey
deal they pay they pay them a contractor
fee
and we pay the materials and so
um and steel doubled
and uh so i've just got to go well do i
really want to do this well yeah i'm
gonna do it but i told him going by the
steel and put it out there in the field
somewhere
so it doesn't double again in the next
18 months while we're screwing around
with this thing but
um but that's the reality steel plywood
uh lumber packages uh glue
uh wire uh there's a shortage of
everything because all the factories
shut down during covet and the shortage
has driven the price up
uh and then add to that that the real
estate market got white hot coming out
of covet in most areas so
i don't i don't think you're being
hoodooed i don't think they're messing
you
over if i did i just pull a plug on
heartbeat just on principle but
uh the other thing is this um you know
10 years from today uh
is this all you're still gonna be
thinking about if you're living in this
house i feel like
probably yeah yeah it's going to eat at
you for the yeah you need to get out of
the deal then
because it's just going to eat at you
okay but i don't think this guy's i
don't think this guy's a crook
okay yeah you know i didn't get that
vibe from them either it's just
they're asking us to take their word
like hey
you know we're telling you we don't know
what the prices are going to be
but please take our word that we're
going to try not to raise the prices and
yeah he's not trying to that didn't work
last time yeah but i mean
but but the difference is unmet
expectations you guys entered into this
nobody saw this lumber shortage coming
and so i mean he's probably built houses
10 years and never faced this one time
and all of a sudden the stinking lumber
package went up you know
a ton and that's the major component in
a residential home is the lumber package
is your biggest item on your line items
and so you know he's he he's like
crap now i gotta go deal now i gotta go
deal with a customer who's gonna be mad
like i did something wrong and i didn't
do anything wrong i just got screwed
myself by the situation so
um i i don't think the guy's a bad guy
um he is passing the cost on to you
which he contractually
nobody ever thought you'd ever activate
that little known clause of the contract
but he's
able to do that and uh so but i think
the biggest thing is
you're just not ever going to be happy
here so you're better off to be done
and um you know you can sit down with
them and tell them that and so you can
either let me go
or i'll you know i'll get a letter uh on
the turn down and then i'll be let go
so um he probably doesn't want to build
a house for you if you're unhappy the
whole time anyway
especially given that he probably has a
line around the block of people wanting
to buy the house without you
so and they'll pay whatever the prices
are
in most cases i don't know but i would
suspect kansas city is
like a lot of these other places right
now zach's in chicago hey zach what's up
hey dave thank you so much for taking my
call sure how can i help
uh i am 33 years old i'm single
and i make about 107
in salary a year i'm looking to buy my
first home
i am pre-approved for a 15-year mortgage
at 2.49
with 20 percent down the only debt i
have is student loans
i have 24 000 in student loan debt
my realtor told me a program about a
program
that forgives student loan debt up to 15
percent
of the purchase price of the house which
would be all of my student loan debt for
24 000 but
in order to qualify for the program i
would have to take a 30-year mortgage
at 3.69
percent which is about even if i pay it
off in 15 years
it's going to cost me about 13 000 over
the two point four nine for 15 years
what is the uh what is the payoff
provision are you allow is there an
early payoff penalty
there is no early there's no prepay
penalty well why not refinance it why
not refinance it six months later
i have to keep it for three years oh
that's a prepayment penalty
okay so your interest on it for three
years is all you're eating not for 30.
yeah not for 30. like i've never heard
of this program this is the wildest butt
thing i've ever heard of
i've never heard of a student loan
forgiveness thing but if the numbers if
the deal works exactly like you're
outlining it
yeah for three years you pay the higher
interest you got rid of all your student
loan and then you refinance at the end
of three years
i'm doing that sure weird
thanks for joining us america this is
the ramsay show i'm your host dave
ramsey open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five mike is
in
atlanta hey mike welcome to the ramsay
show what's up
hey dave um thanks for taking my call
just wanted to
ask a question about downsizing my home
okay
um so here's the deal my wife and i were
able to purchase a
home in 2012 on a short sale for 135
um and the home value has currently gone
up the tax assessor has it at like
um zillow is pulling in at like 280.
yeah
we are wondering about now as a as a
side to this i also have student loan
debt i just put 22 000 down
uh paid 22 000 on my student loans i
currently only have 28
000 left on my student loans so the only
debts we have is our mortgage
and my student loans we've paid off both
cars paid off her student loans
all credit card debt everything is paid
off way to go man
you're doing great i appreciate it my
wife and i've been working at it really
hard
how long have you been working on this
huh well we purchased the home
how long have you been working on this
debt on the debt
about 10 years now way to go
and what's your household income uh
household income
i bring in 65 she brings it i'm a um
i work at the whole i work in
project specialist uh i bring in a 65 a
year and my wife brings
in 52 a year as a teacher good okay
all right and so you only got you only
got 20 something 000 left and you'll be
done
almost there huh exactly well i mean
also including the mortgage we have uh
the remaining balance on our mortgage is
114. yeah so that's that's maybe step
six
so but i mean you're just about finished
with baby step two you're just plowing
right through it you're doing good
how can i help what's your question what
i'm thinking about doing
is repeating the same thing we did
before um
we're looking at uh short sale in
pre-foreclosure homes in the area and
we're wondering if it's pot if we could
should
purchase a tree uh pre-foreclosure or
short sale home
and then sell hours and use the
uh balance to pay off the remainder of
our debts
we only have twenty thousand dollars in
debt you got hundreds of thousands in
equity
sure okay and so what i'm saying is
if we were able to purchase the uh short
sale home
and sell hours we'd be able to pay off
the mortgage of the new home
and or potentially be able to pay off
the mortgage of the new home and
my remaining student loans and once you
can be completely debt free
well you'd sell them you'd sell your
home is how you get rid of that mortgage
but the other home wouldn't be debt-free
would it
um well it depends on what we're able to
do yeah that's the concern
what we're looking for is something very
similar to what we're currently uh
our current situation yeah but things
aren't like they were in 2012
there's not a lot of short sales listen
for a short sale to go through
uh the market has to say nobody's buying
this house
okay for enough to pay off the mortgage
and very few homes are upside down right
now because of the increases in value
so are you is your particular market uh
dormant
um i don't think so we were i went
online and i was able to find one
property that
that meant what we were looking for um
it was somewhere around
135 three bedroom one and a half bath on
a basement
which is enough room for you know my
wife and me my wife and our two boys
is there something you dislike about the
house you're in
no there's it's not that i dislike my
home we just wanted to figure out the
fastest way to run out our debt
and i thought that if we could buy a 135
sell ours around the 250 280 mark
and use that use the the profits from
our home to pay off
the original mortgage and the 135 for
the new home where it's close to all of
the 135 for the new home wouldn't you be
moving down
substantially in-house even if you got a
deal
we're really moving down and like right
now my home is uh
four bedroom two and a half bath on a
full basement um
two-car garage so yes i would be moving
down um because the 135 000 purchase on
a short sale or foreclosure might be
what 175 000
house right if you got a deal right
right
yeah so you're talking about moving down
in order to get debt free house and
everything
that's exactly what i'm talking about
okay um
well don't sell yours until you've got a
deal tied up
for sure but if you can find a deal that
both you and your wife like and it
causes you to be 100
debt free and you all like that more
than you do the house that you're in
uh meaning you like that idea of being
debt-free in a lesser house
i don't have any problem with that
that's not a bad strategy
uh and then you know just save like
crazy and you're probably going to move
up in house
substantially with no house payment no
student loan payments
you know just you know you're making 110
000 you ought to be able to pile up some
cash right
and move up in house in the next three
to five years if you were able to pull
this off
i think that this is going to be harder
than it sounds in your head
because i think the market is so hot
that there's not you're not going to
find as many foreclosures and short
sales as you once did
okay because a house you know when
everything's selling people sell a house
before it goes to foreclosure when
everything's selling
there's no need to short sell it because
they sell it
right and i figured it wouldn't be as
easy as what i'm thinking in my head
which is why i wanted to purchase the
home
first and get under contract for the
show if you want to run out the exercise
just just have the discipline to not do
the deal unless it's the real deal
okay because i think this is going to be
very tough in this current market
um you know i i buy real estate all the
time and i'm not buying real estate
right now
i mean you know i'm well that's not true
i am but it's it's unusual situations
and it's not
because uh it's not like it was in 2008
where i bought
a stuff at a nickel and a 10 and 15
cents on the dollar it was a wonderful
year for buying real estate
but the um but you know that that's not
it's like quite the opposite right now
in general especially when you're
talking about residential stuff
hey mike way to go man you're doing good
have the discipline to not get so caught
up in the idea
that you do a bad deal just to make the
idea happen
because then the then the prob the idea
doesn't work anymore
joe is in new york city hi joe
welcome to the ramsey show hey dave how
are you
better than i deserve man what's up
question for you i'm uh 22 years old i'm
getting married in the fall
um have no debt my fiance and i both
have no debt
great we have about 20 000
in savings but most of that is going to
be used to pay for
the wedding and uh grad school expenses
phenomenal um so my question is
how much should we be
into gazelle modes you know at this
point
you know how much can can i go out
golfing can she go shopping
you know how how committed to
replenishing that savings
should we be and should i pick up a
second job
even though it might take away a little
time from the marriage to help
replenish that savings uh to the extent
that you do not have a fully funded
emergency fund and you don't have grad
school funded
you need to run like your gazelle on
fire but if both of those are funded
then we can relax a little bit
okay but an unfunded emergency fund is
inviting problems into your life
that's like sending out an engraved
invitation to murphy do you know who
murphy is
the guy that says if it can go wrong it
will right
makes sense yeah and so but when you've
got an emergency fund you can like chase
black cats and stuff you know you don't
have to worry about it
so be in gazelle mode until that
emergency fund is fully funded and grad
school and you got grad school covered
because otherwise grad school is going
to turn into that right
right yes sir yeah we we grab school
in the wedding we'll be able to to pay
for those for both of us in cash
phenomenal what are you all still what
are you guys studying
i'm studying theology and
she's education awesome very cool good
for you
well good then yeah as long as you're as
long as your cash flow in grad school
and you've got your emergency fund in
place then we relax a little bit
but baby steps one through three that's
where gazelles are and after that we let
our foot off the gas
and we just go into marathon mode
instead of sprint mode
and you just go you slow down a little
bit and start running so you can finish
an entire marathon
and that's four through seven at that
point and that's what we're talking
about here so if you're avoiding debt
and you have the emergency fund in place
you're paying cash for the wedding
touchdown baby
good job this is the ramsey show
hey guys this is james senior producer
for the ramsay show
did you know over 18 million people
listen to the ramsey show every week
and a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country
to find a station near you head to
thermsyshow.com
this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has
taken the place of the bmw as the status
symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host thank you for
joining us america we're glad you're
here
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five that's triple eight eight
two five
five two five
trisha is with us in detroit to start
off this hour
hi trisha how are you i'm great sir how
are you
better than i deserve what's up well
uh thank you first of all i am um i owe
you guys
a thank you you and ken coleman because
i called last year and got my dream job
and
making more money and much happier good
for you
that's awesome i'm proud of you yeah
thank you so much
um so i we are on steps four five and
six
and i have a question regarding step six
for pay off the house
in conjunction with step five so my
children
are six nine and twelve so obviously the
12 year old much closer to college
is it is it okay dave approved
to pay off the house first and then just
help them pay
cash for college or should we really
just buckle down and 529 it and all
those other things to get them squared
away for college
um it's okay to kind of meet in the
middle so how much do you owe on your
home
uh 139 or yes 130 138 i'm sorry 138 and
your household income is what
um i make 130 my husband makes 90.
math is not my strong suit i'm kidding
okay
220 okay so do 20. you're approaching a
quarter of a million dollars and you
have
six years to pay off a hundred and
thirty nine thousand that's twenty
thousand dollars a year
twenty five thousand yeah
um you can do that and fund college
making a quarter of a million
okay okay if you want to pay it off
faster that's fine
okay so here here's the thing here's the
thing doing
nothing for college i would not suggest
okay because um
you got to walk in the room and look at
those little sets of eyes looking at you
and that's just going to be messing with
your brain
and so if you just simply say all right
we're what we're here's our plan
we're gonna meet with the smart investor
pro and we're gonna put a hundred bucks
a month per kid three hundred dollars
thirty six hundred dollars a year
not spit out of 220 okay
but we're gonna get the kids college
fund started and then we're going to
plow in and we're going to knock out
this house
in like two maybe three years
yes and then we're going to lean into
the 529s harder
and we'll be in a position also to cash
flow college
okay assume assuming you do a good job
of training your children on how to
select a college that is appropriately
priced
uh yes oh i mean being that we're in
michigan they're a little bit more
costly here but
yeah but not but i'm not talking i'm not
talking about an expensive state school
i'm talking about a hundred thousand
dollars a year or something like that
you're not going to have that
kind of money i understand and so
and that's okay by the way they'll
they'll survive i promise
but i mean you can go to the university
of michigan on the plan we're talking
about without any trouble at all or
michigan state university either one
both great schools
both have great great curriculums and uh
you can
you know if they graduate from there
i'll hire them either either way
so yeah i went to ut it was very
affordable yeah university of texas
yeah yeah well i mean it is and um
kelly's in here giving me hook and horn
signs so
but the uh uh and deloney's not here
he'd be doing he'd be like doing some
kind of disco dance right now but um
anyway the uh uh but the yeah the uh
yeah it's it but even they even in that
case michigan is not twice texas
it might be 50 texas but it's not twice
so very affordable very doable but we're
going to train them
like we have to anyway that they need a
job while they're in college
uh that they need to get really good
scores on their acts so they can qualify
for scholarships because free money is
always free
and um and on top of that mom and dad
are gonna do a good job of saving money
and on top of that mom and dad are not
gonna have a mortgage by the time
the first one gets there so we can even
cash flow it
all right let me let me tell you what
you're setting up let me give you a
future prediction okay
just because i i you're you kind of got
this thing right in front of you
and i want to i want to pan back a few
years here's what happened at our house
we did what you're talking about only we
weren't using 529s because they didn't
exist then
we just had utmas meaning the mutual
funds were just in the kids names
okay so we had enough money to pay for
our kids college in each
of their names by the time they got
ready to go to school
and of course we were completely debt
free and this ramsay thing was kicking
off
okay it was actually starting to be
profitable and so
we cash flowed all three of our kids
college
and the pile of money that was in their
mutual funds we handed to them at
graduation to start their lives off
that's awesome and that jump starts that
generation into being millionaires
really quick
that's right so that's what you're
really setting up here
so don't over fund the 529
because i think you're gonna be able to
just put some money in their names that
you hand to them after you cash flow
their college because you'll be able to
cash flow college
because oh by the way we're talking
about six years from now you're not
gonna be making 220 anymore you're gonna
be making 320
yes so more than likely yeah i mean
your your income's going to go up
something i don't know exactly what but
i mean that's very predictable
so um and so will tuition costs but
but but you're going to be great you you
have really thought this through you're
doing a great job but doing
zero for college while you're in four
five and six
just do 50 or 100 bucks or something
just to start to get the muscle moving
and it kind of allows you to emotionally
check the box that i'm not a bad mom or
something you know
you're not but you see what i'm saying
and it just helps you go that way
good question jason's in kansas city hi
jason how can i help
hey dave how are you thanks for
everything that you do we appreciate it
thank you how can i help well quick
question
uh mortgage questions again here uh we
have about 500
extra per month and we're on baby step
six that we can throw up the mortgage
good is it i think i know the answer is
it better throw it at the mortgage
and work that principle down or is it
better to
think about investing that and and using
the interest
and then you know 10 12 years down the
road for the arbitration
paying it off at that time using my
money to help me pay that off faster
yeah in the study of millionaires that
we did studying ten thousand
millionaires we found uh almost zero
that did your second plan
almost all of them did the first plan
just pay off the mortgage
that's my answer and so what we're doing
here is we're studying skinny people and
whatever skinny people do if we want to
be skinny we're doing skinny stuff
you know and that's how it works and so
it's best practices is what we're laying
out and
and that's how also as i've talked to
the way i
put all these principles together a
thousand years ago when this whole thing
just started you know 30 years back
jason was
i talked to old rich people not young
rich people i'd been him he was stupid
and lost
everything i didn't want his opinion i
talked to old rich people
and the things they told me were boring
and didn't even sometimes hardly make
sense but they were just like get out of
debt
stay out of debt live on lessons you
make always be generous
always be living on a plan you know it's
just common sense
only it's not common anymore it's like
having a superpower
this is the ramsey show
hey folks i got a great option to help
you pay for your education
the army national guard the army
national guard believes you
are the next greatest generation because
you have proven that
even in adversity that you have what it
takes to succeed
that's why they offer benefits like
tuition assistance career training
and a paycheck to help you avoid debt no
matter what your goals are the army
national guard can help you
get there visit nationalguard.com to
find out more
when it comes to making big money light
or life moves like buying a home or
getting married or having a baby it's
likely the last thing on your mind to
make sure you have the right insurance
i understand that big changes are
overwhelming
but what would be even more overwhelming
is to find yourself in a situation where
you
and your family are in the hole because
you weren't covered
if not having the time or energy is
what's keeping you from getting the
right insurance coverage
use one of our endorsed local providers
or elp
insurance agents to help elps are
independent agents who
find you the best coverage at the best
price
all you got to do is text the word
insurance to 33
789 and you'll get a free quote doesn't
cost a thing
text insurance to 33789
i'm dave ramsey your host thank you for
joining us open phones at
eight eight two five five two two five
jeremy is in columbus ohio hi jeremy
welcome to the ramsey show hi mr ramsey
how are you doing today
better than i deserve what's up thank
you it's a pleasure to be speaking
to you so my question today is i'm
castling my way through flight school
and i have 40 grand in my savings
account
and i also have um 20 grand
in a mutual fund and another 20 grand in
my 401k
and my question was do you think it's
wise for me to buy a plane
to help me try and save
rent money or should i just continue
renting and invest that money in
something else
just trying to get your thoughts on that
buy a plane
yeah it would save me i pay like 120 an
hour to
rent like for flight school
i do it for i'd buy one for in between
30 and 40 grand
did you divide 120 into 30 000 and
realize that's a lot of hours
i did yeah like there's no break even on
that
yeah however you know now the thing
about a 34 30 or 40 000 airplane is is
that
that's a plane that's probably not going
to lose a lot of value as a matter of
fact since you're kind of hanging around
this stuff all the time
you might actually slip up and buy one
way under market
and make money on it is that possible
that's what i was thinking as well
yeah yeah i also didn't want too much
totaling up in
stuff that goes down in value well it's
not yeah i i don't i don't want you to
either but we're not buying a two
million dollar jet here we're buying a
little single prop that's um exactly
just to build something to build out
yeah what's your household income i'm
saying
i'm only 20 i make right around 70 a
year
what's your car worth 12.
well you know here's the thing again i
i've
um got lots of friends that own planes
and poke around airports and stuff and
planes are a real weird world as you
know
uh but that look that little plane there
if you
if you sneak up if if you could get one
that was appraised at 40 and you bought
it for 30 i would do it yeah
but if you get one that's appraised for
30 and you buy it for 30 i wouldn't do
that
i just wasn't sure if i should be
putting my money in something else
you know in mutual funds in more mutual
funds or
if you think i'm okay to invest in
something like that it's
um it could go down in value
and it is still with your car less than
half your annual income
yeah yeah and so uh if you
okay let's see if we put thirty thousand
dollars in a mutual fund and it made ten
percent that'd be three thousand dollars
if you put thirty thousand dollars in a
plane that's worth forty
and you save all of the rental fees and
then you turn around and sell it for
forty in a couple of years
uh you and that's possible
it is yeah because of the way that
market works but now again
the thing you've got to do is you have
to have the emotional discipline to not
get in an
airplane fever and then just go buy
something and pay what it's worth
because if you pay what it's worth this
is not a good idea you'd have been
better off to put in mutual funds
right and i would be paying with cash i
don't care about that
i know that but i don't care about that
my point is if you don't buy it under
market five or ten thousand dollars
to where you can turn around and sell it
at at at least what you paid for it
later or more
then this is not the math doesn't work
on this you're following me
right yeah that makes sense so you have
to steal one
yeah and otherwise you don't buy it so
i'm putting the money in mutual funds
and then i'm just going to kind of
casually
wander around a few airports and see if
i can sneak up on an airplane that
somebody needs to really sell bad
and uh but if you don't if you and if
you never find one that's okay
just pay your rentals and you'll be fine
yeah
yeah i was kind of hoping to use my
mutual fund money anyways for down
payment on a house
don't then don't do it that's fine so
yeah
you're the one calling me about buying
an airplane so i don't care but yeah um
yeah if that there's nothing wrong with
that plan either that's a great plan
and here's the great news is you're
doing everything you're doing with cash
you're actually thinking about
it and you're paying uh and you're
making money while you're doing all this
so you're not telling me
uh i'm gonna go 200 000 in debt to be a
pilot which is a dumb butt idea
okay uh so and cuz let me tell you as
you know
uh there's something addictive
apparently about flying
um as the pilot uh these pilots get
yeah they they're addict it's like being
on radio they
you know it's it's addictive so you
gotta be careful with it
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two
five mary is with us in dallas texas hi
mary
how can we help hi hi thanks for taking
my call sure
um so all right my husband and i are
starting to look into buying a house in
the future sometime and we've run into
a unique situation
he is still on the mortgage uh for the
house that he lived in with his ex-wife
they've been divorced about four years
and
uh we discovered that it never made it
into the divorce decree
that she had to refinance that house we
have talked to her about this
for a while she was saying i'll do it
i'll do it and then we
get a call from a lawyer saying she
doesn't need to refinance
and now she won't even talk to us about
it and she's saying she doesn't have to
refinance
she doesn't want to get him off of there
she doesn't because your husband's
lawyer was a doofus
well yeah he didn't even have his own
that's a whole other
oh he was his own lawyer which is really
proof he was a doofus
okay so we are in a situation now where
we were told by a loan officer basically
that
worse comes to worse we're going to have
to take that as a debt when we apply for
the loan
yeah it's a contingent liability for
sure and you can't make her you don't
have a legal grounds to make her
refinance it what's the balance on the
loan as
um last i checked it's about 79 000 so
it's not
like it's a huge amount but it's still a
debt
and they're saying that what is your
household income
it is about 125 a year
does she pay the bill on time she does
she pays it on time every
every single month okay
do you know what the interest rate is i
do not
your husband does or he can find out
he's on the market
he doesn't well he can call a mortgage
company
he can call him he's on the mortgage
they can disclose to him all the details
on the mortgage
so here's my here's my only thought you
can't make her do it
no um it's worth
a couple thousand dollars to y'all for
her to do this
so i would offer to pay her closing
costs if she'll refinance
and she gets a better interest rate out
of the deal and no closing costs
so you think it's worth just taking that
bullet
you don't have a choice okay you have a
choice you can't make her do it
right because the doofuses that sign
this divorce decree
he gave up ownership in the house but
kept the liability
it does happen all the time it's not
that unique you said earlier unique it
happens all the time
because people don't think this through
they don't think they're going to end up
where you guys are and everybody does
end up right where you guys are
so you can either accept it as a
contingent liability and forget it and
not worry about it
or if you want to write a check for
three thousand bucks
and uh you know bribe her and and you
know she's got a four percent interest
right now it drops it down to two
something and doesn't cost her a dime
out of pocket maybe then she does want
to do it
but make a proposal that's logical give
her a reason to do it to her attorney
and maybe she'll get off a center or
maybe she'll just be an angry
ex-wife and leave you right where you
are i don't know
this is the ramsay show
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers
to recommend blinds.com is no exception
they offer high quality window
treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering
free shipping and a guaranteed perfect
fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's
special savings
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage
johan and shayna are with us hey guys
how are you
we're very good day thank you it's a
pleasure to be here it's an honor to
have you where do you guys live
uh we we are from maryland in maryland
all right cool and how much debt have
you guys paid off
we've paid off twenty thousand dollars
dave phenomenal and how long did this
take you
it took us 11 months good for you and
your range of income during that time
we started at 60 000 and we ended with
63
000. gosh that's amazing so what kind of
debt was your 20 000
so 3 000 was a car loan and 17 000 was a
credit card
okay all right so you're just kind of
normal how long you guys been married
one year and four months today all right
congratulations
thank you and so right after marriage
you decide to attack this dad tell me
the story
so it was october 2019 we were engaged
in getting ready to get married
in december and i
was i went to a bakery because i really
wanted to buy
cinnamon rolls for our young women's
discipleship group
i was already 11 000 in credit card debt
at that time
and i walked into the store knowing all
this
and the cinnamon rolls was eleven
dollars
and i knew that i had
um a conflict between what i wanted to
do versus
what i had resources to do
and so at that moment when i bought the
cinnamon rolls
i cried out to god and i said lord jesus
i have a bad relationship with money
so i went home and i looked up online
how to reheat the cinnamon rolls
and i found a blog called stacy at
humorous homemaking
and she taught me how to reheat the
cinnamon rolls but on the side
um she had an article that says we live
debt free
and i clicked on that link and i read
all about it and i found your plan
you heard oh my god i never have gotten
anybody through cinnamon rolls before
this is my favorite ever i love
cinnamon rolls me too this is great i
like them even more now
this is great wow so way to go what's
the guy's name what's up
stacy you said yes stacy at humorous
homemaking
all right way to go stacy thank you
that's awesome
very cool so uh you you you called up
johan and said uh
we're gonna we're gonna do this yes what
did what did johan say
i just said okay whatever you want to do
yeah you learned quick i think yeah i'm
glad
he uh she told about the depth
yeah because if
we i i didn't know about this until
long time it would be hard to
yeah spend marriage life i think yeah
yeah absolutely yeah yeah you don't want
to keep secrets
yeah you need to know you need to know
what's going on that's very wise
so uh was uh was all of this yours then
shaina coming into this marriage yes
johann had none
that's correct so he got you and the
debt yes he did then the two of you your
first order of business is roll up your
sleeves and knock it out
and no more doubt how does it feel to be
free amazing
did your relationship did jesus answer
your prayer your relationship with money
changed
absolutely yes yes he gave us a plan he
he knows our hearts he knows we want to
give and he
gave us the plan um in order to be able
to do that
and how to give generously so we thank
you wow you're
you're incredible i'm proud of you guys
very very well done
what do you tell people the secret to
getting out of that is
uh i think
we make budget and
we plan planned a lot of things in
budget
it's helped out a lot i think yeah
yeah haven't again because yeah
when we went uh
grocery store we just buy something
what we want but it's not good for
saving money so right right yeah
having a plan and sticking to it yeah i
also think that
um the key to getting out of debt is
your relationship with god
because when we follow what he convicts
us to do
according to his word then he just
provides everything and it's
like i had to really wrestle with
tithing
and when i obeyed god's word he just
gave us money month after month after
month in addition to
uh our salary and it was incredible just
to see
watching god work through getting out of
debt
and not only did he give us the ability
to pay off all of our debt but he also
gave us the ability to
fully fund our emergency fund and invest
10 percent of our income in retirement
for the year 2020.
wow so god is good wow you guys well you
had a plan and you did it
so what is the secret to heating up
cinnamon rolls
um i think you have to put them in the
oven uh
i forget the degrees but i think it's
about 20 minutes
okay 350 i think all right my mouth's
kind of watering right now i'm just
saying
well congratulations you guys we're very
very proud of you we've got a copy of
the legacy journey book for you which is
my latest and it'll
take you into the next steps of the
whole baby steps process and on through
uh
completely changing your legacy and
you'll enjoy it it's
written from a uniquely christian
perspective and also i'm going to give
you an extra copy of the total money
makeover book
uh so you can give it to someone who
needs this help because someone's been
inspired by you
that is in your life and this will give
you a way to pay it forward so
excellent good job you guys i'm so proud
of you
well done all right it's johan and
shayna from
maryland 20 000 paid off in 11 months
making 60 to 63. blame it all on the
cinnamon rolls
count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream
we are dead free
this is how it's done
you just never know when you're sharing
what's happening in your life how it's
gonna
show up in someone else's life pretty
amazing
uh find out for yourself why blinds.com
is the number one online retailer for
custom window coverings they're the
sponsor of our question of the day
you'll get free samples free shipping
and with the new promos they run every
month you'll save even more
use the promo code ramsey to get the
best possible deal robbie's in michigan
the new monthly child tax credit was
recently announced
is it the best is it best to opt in or
opt out of this
not aware you could opt out i think it's
just tax law if it comes to play
and if it passed i missed it maybe it
did pass
but um it may be just something that
you've got in michigan too
robbie that may be why i've missed it
but um
anyway uh if you can opt in
and uh you get a tax credit and there's
no expense to you later
it doesn't come back to bite you later
then you would opt in
if you even have the option very few tax
laws give you the option to opt in or
opt out so
honestly i'm pretty ignorant about what
you're asking about so i think i'm
screwing this answer up but
anyway open phones at triple eight eight
two five
five two two five so
the point of the debt-free scream
is to let all of you guys know that it
does not matter
what your obstacles are it does not
matter what your income is
it does not matter what your situation
is there are
now thousands
thousands of debt free screams on the
youtube channel
i can promise you one of them
is just like you
very similar to you
and what that proves is that you
can not only get out of debt but you can
enjoy the benefits of being out of debt
which is the ability to build wealth
the ability to be outrageously generous
which is tough to do when you're broke
people
turns out that hungry kids are very
seldom fed by
hungry kids
this is the ramsey show
so
thanks for joining us america luther is
with us in athens
georgia hi luther welcome to the ramsey
show
hey thank you uh so much for taking my
call sure what's up
all right uh so um
i'm in baby step number two uh i only
have eight thousand dollars
left on my car note and i'll be debt
free
um my situation though is
uh pretty much this time last year
uh i actually got a divorce
and i got full custody of my now
two-year-old son
and so right now i'm working a
job that's pretty much a dead-end job
i make 24 000 i made 24
dollars last year uh i started up
a a a business
that i'm super passionate about and it
surrounds
fatherhood and promoting fatherhood
but right now i'm at a point to where
where i'm living at right now i'm not
paying
rent it's just a friend being a friend
and helping us out but they're looking
at selling the
uh this property and
uh me being a single parent i'm
not in this i'm not in a good
spot to go out on my own
without getting this business running
but i've been so afraid to get it going
i haven't even gotten inventory for it
i've just done the initial startup
of it so i'm wondering should i
focus on carrying the baby steps out
all the way to
ending my debt or should i focus on
uh building up this business
wow how old are you i'm
28. um you got family in your area there
or who's helping you with your
with your child i've got one aunt uh
who's in the area and she helped out a
lot
probably more than she could probably uh
handle and i'm so thankful for that
um but the friends that uh
that are giving me this place they
actually have another place down south
uh so and i know you're really strong
against long-distance landlording
so i don't want to put them in that
position
and i'm super grateful for them helping
me out but
i don't want to overstep
and over you know overstep my welcome
well it's good that you put together a
sustainable life without free housing
that's being given to you out of
someone's heart
on the short term that's a wonderful
gift and you know
it's good for you to accept that gift on
the long term
you you're smart to say you're wise to
say i i want a better plan
uh because it's not sustainable to live
uh
to live that way um and so
okay if you were to get the business
moving
is there not some way you can go ahead
and start now how much money do you need
to start it why do you need a bunch of
money just do it
um i guess i've just been afraid uh i've
been
building up my emergency
savings uh because of me knowing that
i only have a limited time here yeah you
don't need to pay any extra on your car
right now
you just need to pile up cash so what do
you need to buy to get to make money in
this business
i need it's
probably about uh right under two
thousand dollars uh
to actually start making sales uh to get
inventory in
and how much do you have saved five
thousand
okay so why can't you start it with a
thousand dollars
uh i can i can uh cut back on uh
the products that i want to launch and i
can launch
you know two or three instead of five or
six you're launching them online
uh yeah that would be the uh that would
be the plan okay so someone
sees your product online and orders it
right how long does it take to produce
these products
if people ordered more than you had in
inventory
uh it would be about uh two weeks
uh would be the uh from production to uh
getting it in hand and shipping it okay
all right so if you put on the website
delivery in
two to three weeks that would be telling
the truth
and you could buy a limited number of
uh of items in other words you don't
have to have a full stock
if you can do a two-week turnaround
right
uh yeah that's correct okay well let's
get that going tonight
oh okay oh i mean you don't you you know
500
worth will get you enough to get the
website going right and then you just
anybody that orders something you
reorder every two weeks you use their
money to build it from there right
uh yeah that's correct yeah can you
order one offs
um i can but it's just
uh more expensive it wouldn't be yeah it
would be more expensive yeah i'd carry
more overhead for them
instead of like bulk orders no you'd
carry more cost of goods sold
or cost right yeah yeah and so you can't
afford bulk holders dude you're broke
yeah and you don't want to order bulk in
something that you don't even know if it
can sell yet
correct so you you want to limit the
amount of stuff you throw away when you
launch a new product
because one thing's for sure launch a
new product you don't know what you
don't know
right you're going to learn some stuff
in this process believe me i've done a
bunch of what you're talking about doing
and so it's going to go slower than you
thought you would so
uh in the meantime let's also look for a
better job
okay yeah i can i can totally do that
yeah because you're you're looking for
an excuse to do that
yeah yeah i mean you need because listen
if you could get a job making 40
that would change your world yeah
yeah uh right now what's kind of holding
me back is uh
uh in the area that i'm in uh it's so
rural
that uh not a lot of places are uh
really paying that much uh but
uh i can definitely start looking out
further well let's try this
okay if you found a job making 50 000
and it was not in the area that you're
in you would move
yeah i would and you could afford to
move
right so um you know
let's move to town
all right yeah that i'm good with that
because
because this this business unless you
just hit a nerve and the thing just goes
zoom zoom
which very seldom happens most things
move if they burn
slow they don't burn fast it takes a
little while to get things moving you
adjust the product
you make it a little better you change
the design a little bit and every time
you do it sells a little bit
more a little bit more a little bit more
but very seldom do you just launch a
singular thing and it becomes a huge
massive hit the one thing it's that's
just
very very unusual in business and so
as you adjust this product and get it to
where it's where it's really selling
like crazy
it you may it may take you 18 months to
two years
uh meanwhile you're starving to death
and gonna end up homeless
right right yeah so i want you to get
some stable employment under you
uh check out ken coleman's website he
can help you a bunch with that i'll send
you a copy of his book the proximity
principle
to help you begin to think about a
different uh
even if it's a short-term career so if
you work a new job
that's a better job that pays double
what you're paying now
which is still not an ultra high paying
job by any stretch of the imagination
you give yourself the
financial patience to raise your child
without worrying about being hungry
and to be able to run this business
without having to live out of the
business for a little while
and it keeps you from making desperate
choices in the business
and uh it'll move you in the right
direction so
hey man you got a tough road but you are
you're a strong guy and you're gonna do
this
you're gonna figure it out but uh
because you got a lot on your plate no
question about it but i think you're
going to make it
i think 10 years from now you're going
to look back and go wow those are some
tough times
and i learned a lot during those times
our thanks to james childs our producer
kelly daniel our associate producer i am
dave ramsey your host
we'll be back
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life
let them know about the ramsey call of
the day podcast
it's a quick hit of advice about life
and money in
under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day
podcast wherever you listen to podcasts
this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice i'm dave
ramsey your host thank you for joining
us open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
that's triple eight eight two five five
two two five joseph is with us to start
off this hour in puerto rico hi
joseph how are you i'm doing well dave
thank you so much for taking my call i
appreciate it
certainly how can i help all right about
five years ago
i'm gonna give you kind of a snapshot of
who we are and what's going on here so
that uh
you can kind of answer my question when
i tell you the end of it here
uh we moved to puerto rico about five
years ago to start a new ministry
and uh we rented our home and about
three years ago
our small group bible study we're trying
to decide what's our next bible study
going to be
and we're like we all stink at managing
our money
we all give our lives insecure
insecurities and you know we're just not
very good at it we're living paycheck to
paycheck we're not saving for retirement
so our small group bible study decided
to go through financial peace university
so the eight of us
uh took this course together and um
in the last three years we've paid off
about ten thousand dollars in debt
uh we've saved our thousand dollars
emergency fund put 25 000 in the bank
for
our six months of emergency you know
reserves
and started finally investing in
retirement um
and like i said uh we've been renting
our home
and um about six months ago our landlord
came to us
and said hey i he moved to texas about
five years ago
and uh when we took the we started
renting here and he came to us and said
hey
i want to get out of this house i want
to sell it
but i'm going to give you guys the first
option and so he's like i'll just ask
for what i owe on it
um and we're like started panicking
we're like okay we don't have money to
buy a house right now because we're just
putting all of our money into retirement
and trying to save up for that because
we were so behind on it and um so we
started looking around for another place
to rent
the rental market here is totally dried
up um there's so many people moving here
for the tax benefits in puerto rico that
all rentals are just like astronomically
high
um and so we're looking back now at
at purchasing this home um it's
you could sell it for about two full see
there's there's
houses in the market right now for about
249 250 same houses in our neighborhood
um he owes 200 on it and
so we have our we don't have the 20
down payment per se saved up but we have
our six months
fund and we have our about twenty five
thousand dollars
between our two emergency no no i'm
sorry not emergency
it's about twenty five thousand dollars
between our two iras
and then we have our ten thousand
dollars invited money that
that just came in so we have that money
sitting there
and we're planning on using that towards
putting
our 20 down on the house even if you
don't put even if you don't put down
20 that's okay on a first home purchase
the only problem is you're going to get
the pmi but
it's not a requirement that we give you
in financial peace university on your
first home purchase that you put down 20
as long as you understand that you're
taking out pmi
and so you're getting private mortgage
insurance which just adds to the expense
of the house obviously
so um yeah yeah i would uh scrape
together and add some to the 10
i would not use your emergency fund i
would not use your ira but if
you can buy this house and put some
money with that 10 and
uh or if you back your emergency fund
down a little bit and say
it's six months and we're gonna back it
down to three months that's okay
because it's still in the three to six
months range but we're not going to use
your emergency fund we're certainly not
cleaning out your iras
but i would stop adding to them right
now while we work on this how long have
you got to purchase it how long will he
give you
um well we we actually went into the
contract with them so
we were in the contract process so why
did you call me or you already did your
deal yeah
i guess because i'm nervous about you
know that question of whether or not we
should
liquidate the ira no you should and uh
use all our money and that's where i was
kind of not finding an answer yeah no
you should
kind of find that so i've never told
i've never told someone to liquidate an
ira to buy a house
ever um no you shouldn't but the 10 000
will be enough
that should get you into it and anything
else you can scratch together between
now and closing how far can you delay
the closing stop your
retirement savings and power cash on
pile cash on power cash on sell
everything in sight pile cash on to get
you a good strong down payment on top of
that ten
that's all fine and again if you crank
down that
if you have a six month emergency fund
and you back it down to
three months that's not the end of the
world uh you may want to beef it up
later again but as long as you're in
that three to six months range but no
we're not using the whole emergency fund
i wouldn't use a dime
of your retirement account and then um
the payment needs to be a fourth of your
take-home pay on a 15-year fixed rate
and you should have known that from
going through financial peace university
we did teach you that so
hopefully that does fit in with your
income in this situation but it sounds
like it's a good buy
and um and you're you're at the right
place to do it you're just trying to
scrape together some nickels out of the
corner of the couch to make it work
that's all you can pull it off john's
with us in dallas hi
john welcome to the ramsay show
hey dave what's up better than i desire
yeah
i advise at a college and i got in
trouble with my bosses because i told
some students coming in
for advising that i didn't think general
studies was a good choice of major
and my bosses are putting pressure on me
to promote this degree
and all of our degrees equally and
you know you talk about useless degrees
a lot i was just curious what do you
think of the general studies degree
and what would you do if you were in my
situation and i think i'm just going to
hang up and listen
thank you thank you i appreciate your
call
um
general studies degree assumes that all
education is profitable in the
marketplace and we've proven that it's
not
um education is important
the more you know the better life you'll
have
and if you know some of the things that
the marketplace actually appreciates
then the better income you'll have but
um you know
which is why i read like a maniac still
and i haven't been in college in years
and so adding education
adding knowledge um even if it's just
weird knowledge on a hobby you're
working on that still just adds to the
quality of your life
and so in that sense a general studies
or a liberal arts degree
or whatever you want to call it is uh is
fine just for a well-rounded life
but it is not the equivalent
of some of the other degree fields
uh and in terms of what the person can
do with their life as a result of it uh
and so you know you'd be much better off
uh not going to college
and uh getting some technology
certificates
uh you make a lot more money and uh
uh you'd be much better off studying a
field of study that
uh you know young people coming out with
supply chain logistics
degrees now are making eighty ninety
thousand bucks coming out
they're not coming out making that with
general studies
uh and so uh uh
you know if uh what would i do if i'm in
your shoes well
it sounds like you're working for an
idiot to me
you know they're asking you to promote
things that are as if they're equal when
they're not
and they're asking you to go against
your integrity in other words you have
to lie
now to students to please your boss
and so it sounds like i'm not working
there much longer i'm going to be doing
something else with my life i guess
i've done that a few times in my life
hey folks i got a great option to help
you pay for your education
the army national guard the army
national guard believes you
are the next greatest generation because
you have proven that even in adversity
that you have what it takes to succeed
that's why they offer benefits like
tuition assistance career
training and a paycheck to help you
avoid debt no matter what your goals are
the army national guard can help you
get there visit nationalguard.com to
find out more
have you ever made a dumb decision with
zeros on the end because you did not do
your research
yeah me too
most people make choices based on
feelings
or opinions especially when doing
something like buying a house but
when it comes to the real estate market
feelings are not your friends
facts are your friends so check your
facts
find out what you can actually afford
research what's trending in home prices
talk to a reputable real estate agent in
your area
listen if you're thinking of selling a
home in this crazy market we're in right
now
this is not amateur hour anybody can
sell a house yeah
monkey can sell a house but they're not
necessarily going to get the most
for it right now and uh some
you know some people that get their real
estate license they don't know what
they're doing any more than a monkey
would know
and so you need a pro in your corner you
need somebody knows what they're doing
you need to get with one of our real
estate elps or endorsed local providers
never buy a house without the facts
and you gotta ha this isn't listen you
need a pro because this is a weird
market and you're you could lose tens of
thousands of dollars
by someone not knowing how to navigate
the craziness that's out there right now
and uh you really gotta have somebody
knowing what they're doing right now
so text house to 33 789 particularly if
you're getting ready to sell a house
text house 233789
paul is with us in mcallen texas hey
paul
welcome to the ramsey show
and i love the lead end music so i just
have a question i've got kind of a crux
in my life right now
and i could use a little advice because
it's kind of tricky okay
so pretty much i live down here it's an
affordable
way of life but i've been in a position
in higher education for about 10
plus years and there's little to no
upward mobility
and of course you know you look at going
on to further your education it's no
guarantee
you might make 10 000 or more you know
it's not really worth the return on
investment
recently i was given or possibly given
an opportunity to
look at moving to santa barbara
california
to work i might add also in higher
education
but for substantially more i own a home
which is a as i like to say
large garden small farm operation here
where i am
and i really would not like to let it go
but uh i have been trying to look for
opportunities in the job market in this
area for a very long time and i have not
found
much in the way of upward mobility again
so i'm just wondering is this um
potential opportunity in california even
though i realize it is a very high-end
expensive place to live although it is
paradise
um you know is it really worth looking
at doing something like that even for
just a couple of years to
put back into the property here and
renting or selling
or even just you know it's really just
one of those things where i'm trying to
get my my finances on track and
this came about what do you make now oh
about 40. what would you make there
yeah about 80 to 85 is the estimate of
course i would fight for more
but you know that's about the estimate
okay oh yeah there's no hope of owning
real estate in that area unless there
was some long-term investment
um but yeah you know it would be how did
you how did this lead come about
well it's through a very old friend of
mine um very old colleague
and he's in the opportunity and is
looking for
people that he can trust and and
know that work hard and for good so i
mean that's kind of
yeah that's how it came about
what do you do in higher education well
i help with administering scholarships
for students
at the moment but i've also worked in
public information
and i've also worked in grant writing
and this would be working in more of an
i.t kind of project management situation
so you have a phd in higher ed or what
i do not i have a bachelor's i have two
bachelor's degrees and an associate
degree and i'm about to finish up a
certificate
in project management in the next
probably four weeks
who says you have to stay in higher
education
nobody does but i have i have tried
literally i have tried it's like part of
my uh
work schedule week spend two or three
hours looking for work
and apply apply apply and i've just not
i've just not hit the target for
whatever reason
okay um i know it's
tough right i know i i think if you had
other options you wouldn't even be
looking at this one
no i don't have many options no i wonder
what i said that wasn't what i said i
said if you had if you had three or four
options on the table
i know you told me you didn't have
options but if you had if you had an 80
000
option in dallas you wouldn't even be
talking about this
well you're cutting out we had a bit of
a cutout there
okay i said if you had an 80 000 option
in dallas you wouldn't even be talking
about this
and so i think that what this has done
is it has
woken you up uh and probably your job
hunt technique sucks
and we got to work on that and um and
let's get you some more options to look
at
because i i mean if you want to do this
there's nothing evil in what you're
talking about but it sounds kind of
a little bit desperate like it's the
like it's the only
thing out there and it's just not that's
just not true that's a scarcity
mentality
and it's just not now just book you just
hadn't been able to land the right thing
so
what i would tell you is i'm going to
send you a copy of ken coleman's book
the proximity principle
and uh i and if you've got degrees in
areas outside of higher education and
you've
been having trouble finding upward
mobility in higher education in your
area
then let's get outside of higher
education and let's start looking at
project management anywhere you just got
a certificate on that the project
management
uh pm1s pm2s or you know they're making
more than you're making
and uh they're certainly making more
than you're making in houston dallas san
antonio
austin for sure and uh and i i didn't
even leave your state yet
so uh and i'm not against you going to
the other place
i it just feels like you're considering
it because you feel like it's the only
possible path
to make more money and i don't i just
don't believe that is the case so i'm
going to send you a copy of the
proximity principle once you get on king
coleman's website i want you to learn
everything he has about hunting for a
job about doing your resume
about the interview techniques about how
to get your foot in the door and get
your name out of the pile because all
these applications you're filling out go
in a pile with 2 000 other people
and nobody ever sees your app again
you get buried you have to do something
to differentiate yourself and ken can
show you how to do that go to ken
coleman.com and he can walk you through
all of that
so hey man thanks for the call folks
when you're
facing a decision of any kind
and none of the odds
and the you know you've got like two
options and neither one of them are
great or it feels like it's very very
limited or very trapped
and you get kind of we all get kind of
fatalistic about it it's like oh well
that's the only
thing it's almost never the only thing
and so what i've had to learn to do is
the more
options i have two things occur
no matter what it is you're looking at
if you're looking at buying a car if
you're looking at a career change
if if you're uh looking for a wife
i mean the more options you have the
more
power you have and the more likely you
are to
make the right decision when you only
have two
options and you feel trapped very seldom
is either one of those the right option
and so you need more options to give you
power
to not feel trapped and to make a better
decision in
every case and there's no difference
with him
this is the ramsey show
thank you for joining us america
jonathan is in lubbock texas
hey jonathan welcome to the dave ramsey
show
hey dave how are you better than i
deserve what's up
hey so i'm faced with kind of a unique
situation i've been
pretty blessed with some amazing parents
that have been great role models and
all areas of life especially financially
and they taught
financial peace to sunday schools and
even made me read financial peace which
i didn't enjoy at the time but i'm super
grateful now
that um so i'm 19 years old i just
graduated high school i'm i just i'm
about to finish up my first year at a
community college
um and i've been able to go completely
free based off scholarships and
even some going back towards me for
getting to put back for later and
leftovers and
my situation kind of surrounds i've i'm
planning to continue and
get a bachelor's degree and i even i'm
even planning past that and want to get
a law degree in the future
yet through reading and having great
mentors and
all that i've learned through reading
about money and
especially through yells programs i know
that the time
prudence of saving for retirement so my
uh my course in stems i have enough
money saved
my my family does to be able to fully
pay for
all the way up to my bachelor's degree
but i have siblings too and so i
understand
my my law school will be kind of a cash
flows
system when it gets to that point but my
question is um i've been
putting money into my roth ira that i
set up last year
and um contributing as
as much as i can but financially
thinking smartly about
you know paying for other things and
i've been sitting down with my parents
talking about that
but my question is should i continue to
contribute to my retirement savings
while i have this desire to go to a
graduate school that i'm not entirely
sure
i'll have funds for upfront no you
should not
okay you should stop saving for
retirement and you should put all your
money aside
to complete the education track that
you're on
uh and the reason is this you
uh what you can make in the marketplace
extra as a result of these degrees
is a lot more than you will make on a
mutual fund
right education that is usable in the
marketplace to increase your income
is always more valuable
than a mutual fund now education this
left-handed puppetry is not
i mean you get a degree in underwater bb
stacking or something it's of no value
right
and people get these stupid butt degrees
but if you're going to go get a law
degree and then you're going to use the
law degree
to create an incredible income as an
attorney
uh and get on a really strong career
path
of law whatever that is in whatever
version of the law it is but i mean
you're not gonna uh
go to work for thirty thousand dollars a
year for the state doing nothing i'm
talking about you're going to go out
there and you're going to use the law
degree to make
a couple of hundred or more a year as a
result of being an attorney and
developing a career
in that area that is going to give you a
better mathematical return
on your investment than a mutual fund
will
and you have plenty of time to do your
investing i don't want you to put it off
forever
but your education with the track you're
on jonathan and the kind of a young man
you
are is more valuable the way you're
laying it out
than a mutual fund is so no i would stop
and pile up cash and let's get let's get
this law degree and let's pay cash for
it and
a big old pile of cash and if you have a
bunch of cash left over because you
piled up such a big pile
when you graduate you got a big old pile
left oh well we'll try to figure it out
you know
lane is in lincoln nebraska hi lane how
are you
doing well dave hey first of all let me
just say thanks so much for all you and
your team do
it's an honor to speak with you honor to
speak with you sir god bless you how can
we help
uh yeah so hey um last year the year of
the dumpster fire
me and my wife were actually able to
become
debt free finish baby step two first
time in the eight years of our marriage
which was awesome
great and then i guess you could say
partially thanks to
government stimulus if that's possible
we sped through
baby step three and we're able to
upgrade an old car so we found ourselves
at steps four five and six
quicker than we expected wonderful but
that's a huge blessing
wonderful um i am a pastor and currently
we
live in the church parsonage um it is
it's a very nice nice home we're
thankful for it i know that's not always
the case
um but my question is kind of you know
whether
we love the church we're at but whether
we're here for five years ten years or
till i retire we realize that eventually
we will have to buy a home and when that
time comes we don't want to be starting
from nothing at that point so my
question is where should
we be saving money for this future home
i would start paying a small house
payment
into a mutual fund and then that's your
mutual fund
yeah that's just your home purchase fund
later uh it could be sooner
it could be later it could be much later
i don't know how long you're going to be
in the parsonage either
but having worked with pastors for 30
years if
if you just fast forward this out 30
years from today
and you never save money for a house and
then the
your you know your pastoral career you
go into retirement you don't have the
parsonage anymore
you don't have a house yeah exactly
that's a problem
and so you know i don't know whether
this is gonna you know maybe you move
five years from now to a different
position and they don't have a parsonage
then you would be ready to buy then
or i don't know whether it's 40 years
after from today
and this parsonage is over you know and
you just you spend your whole career at
that church which
either one's fine with me i'm you know
whatever i'm open to whatever god's got
for you
but uh but i do know that if you save
money it's gonna keep you in a position
of uh uh uh well to be able to buy a
house it's that simple so yeah just
start
you know pretend your baby six baby step
six is
is really there as if you had a mortgage
but instead of paying off the mortgage
you're building up cash to buy the house
and so whatever you would put onto baby
step six
and you might want to just set up a
mutual fund with your smart vester pro
or even just a an index fund it'd be
fine
but just automatically draft it out of
your checking account each month
a small house payment depending on what
your household income is
i mean if you start putting a thousand
bucks a month aside and you do that for
a decade you're gonna have some serious
money in that account
to buy a house maybe even pay cash for a
house so
put you in really good shape zach is
with us in new jersey hi zach welcome to
the ramsay show
thank you for having me how are you
better than i deserve how can i help
um so i'm 20 years old married with a
kid on her life
and i've been watching a lot of youtube
videos for the past month or two
and getting debt free is definitely at
the top my priority list now
good um my wife and i own
two cars one of them is paid off the
other one
is thirty thousand dollars uh in loan
um in total we have 120 000 the
other 90 000 is student loans um
and we're getting to the point where her
car has too many miles
because she drives anywhere from 40 to
60 000 miles a year
um my solution to that was that she
would take
my car which has 10 000 miles i would
take the
other car and she would drive this until
he needed another car works paid off
um however she's since she spends so
much time
in a vehicle every year she's pretty
particular about what she wants
and so she really wants to trade
the car that we have now that is thirty
thousand dollars in debt
and buy something that's forty to forty
five thousand dollars in that
um and i kind of had worked out a plan
with her where we can pay off
fifteen thousand dollars in six months
and at that point since the payment
would be gone from the other loan we
would work ourselves into
potentially buying that car no not a
chance dude
listen listen i don't give a crap what
she's particular about
you guys are broke you are deeply in
debt
up to your eyeballs and now you're
talking about buying a freaking
45 000 car and put 60 000 miles a year
on it and destroy its value
zack that's dumber than a rock man
absolutely not
not a chance
so
our scripture of the day proverbs 3 5
and 6 trust in the lord with all your
heart and lean not
on your own understanding in all your
ways acknowledge him and he
shall direct your paths benjamin
franklin said an investment in knowledge
pays the best interest
mary is with us in dallas texas hi mary
welcome to the ramsey show
thank you dave i just have a question
about yearly home
insurance that you purchase i
own a home it's totally paid off i have
no debt
i have savings and i was just
wondering is it prudent
to and i i just made a claim and we had
hail and
they're going to be replacing the roof
for me so
uh that will hopefully last for another
20 20 years or so so i just wondered if
that was a prudent idea
if what keeping homeowners insurance
excuse me not buying the homeowner's
insurance
no it is not prudent i would buy
homeowners insurance
okay i have homeowners insurance on my
home and i can write a check and replace
it tomorrow if it burns down but it is a
good buy to insure it
um all of my properties that i own i
have insurance on and i have the ability
to replace all of them financially if
something happened without that but it
is a
it's good risk management to transfer
the risk of a fire or a tornado or
another catastrophic event now what i
would do
is i would raise your deductible up good
and high
so ask your homeowners i do two things
one is i'd shop your homeowner's
insurance
if you haven't shopped it with an
independent insurance agent you can go
to daveramsey.com and click elp for
insurance
they'll shop a bunch of different
companies and get you the best price
number one do that
okay if you haven't because you may get
a much better price
number two um
get the price on the deductible and i'll
teach you how to
analyze that what is your current
deductible
uh i think it's uh two percent
two percent that's unusual
it's usually 500 or a thousand dollars
or five thousand dollars or
no it's it's a percentage of
uh of the value of the home that they
have insured
interesting so how much do they have
insured
they have it insured for 249
000. okay so you have a five thousand
dollar deductible
uh basically yeah approximately okay
that's a very high deductible so you
probably aren't gonna
you're probably not gonna gain anything
by raising it from five to ten
but you could ask okay because you know
i'm not worried about a ten thousand
dollar loss for you
i'm worried about a 250 000 loss
right and so if we can if you can get a
substantially cheaper price by
going from 2 to 4 with your company or
by getting a 5 000
deductible with somebody else and our
ten thousand dollar deductible with
somebody else
see here's the way you look at it what
are you paying in premiums now
i think it's uh if i'm not mistaken it's
it's around 1200 a year okay so let's
pretend we went from
five thousand dollar deductible to ten
thousand dollar deductible two percent
to four percent okay
uh you're taking an extra five thousand
dollars worth of risk
and if they drop the price a hundred
dollars
for you doing that from 1200 to 1100 you
can divide that hundred
into that five thousand and you figure
out real quickly that that's
50 months um probably not doing that one
but if they drop the price two or three
hundred dollars
for you to take an extra 5 000 risk you
don't have that many claims on this
then then you would you know i would
take i run
really high deductibles on all my stuff
because again it's not the first five or
ten thousand that i'm worried about
it's the first 250 000 the back 250 000.
nathan's with us in universal city texas
hi nathan how are you
doing good sir yourself better than i
deserve how can i help
yes sir so my question is is it wise to
share
a room with my girlfriend so my company
is sending me
on a trip to maui my one summit this
year
so they're sending me for a week and i
get to take one other person with me
i'd like to take my girlfriend with me
but
i don't know if it's a wise decision to
lodge in the same bedroom okay
are you all already living together
sleeping together
no sir okay so this will be violating
that
right right we're trying to abstain
until marriage
yes sir okay uh and how old are you sir
25 okay um
i mean you you certainly can do whatever
you want but you're asking me which is a
mistake because i'll tell you
so um i would get a separate call yeah
i'd get a separate bedroom
because uh if i'm 25 years old i don't
have that much willpower
right i mean really you're just asking
for
a situation that apparently based on
you're telling me what your values are
that you're going to regret
you're just asking for trouble
right on top of that um
i don't really care how people think
about the way it looks but i care about
the way something looks for my wife
and i don't want to compromise her
reputation and i'm going to guess and
say
if you're concerned about this kind of
thing like i would be
we share that value system then i would
be concerned about what people thought
about my wife
that's a true statement yes sir yeah so
i mean you like her dad
right mainly her dad honestly
yeah and uh you know because you know
every all of us
guys are going yeah you might pull that
off but you probably won't
you know and why put yourself through
that oh my gosh uh
so now as a matter of reputation
of the lady that you love we'll be very
old-fashioned here we're going to
protect her reputation
to her dad to her friends because you've
made this statement that you're going to
wait until marriage
then let's let's put a situation in
place that leaves no one
questioning that you did much less uh
having to have that kind of
self-discipline
which uh 25 there was no chance
oh so nathan you're a good young man you
have a good heart
we need more people like you in america
today there are so few of you
uh thank you sir i'm honored to speak
with you today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five yes there are people out
here
like me that are dinosaurs that actually
believe
that we're supposed to be married
before we engage in sexual activity like
that
yeah it's it's i know it's i know it's
hard to believe for some of you
you can't grasp the concept but it's a
part of my christian faith i actually do
believe that um i didn't always i wasn't
always a christian
and it's my faith has informed me on
that and it's not a
not a question in my mind but it seems
to be a foreign
concept in a culture that has become so
toxic
of foreign concepts um uh does my
does my old heart my old dinosaur heart
good to talk to a nathan that is
actually concerned
gallant young gentleman concerned about
his fiancee and actually cares
what her dad thinks what a man of honor
oh don't we need more men of honor
and more women of honor men of virtue
women of virtue they're getting more and
more rare it's almost like having a
superpower nowadays
so well thank you sir you did my heart
good today i appreciate talking to you
that about puts this particular hour of
the ramsey show
in the books james childs is our
producer
kelly daniel is our associate producer
and phone screener
first time i've done a show by myself in
a long time i feel kind of lonely in
here
that puts this hour of the show in the
books we'll be back with you before you
know it in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace
and that's to walk daily with the prince
of peace
christ jesus
hey it's kelly associate producer for
the ramsay show
this episode is over but if you heard
about an event product or service and
didn't have a chance to write it down
don't worry we list everything you've
heard about during this episode in the
podcast show notes section or head to
theramsi show.com
thanks for listening
you